it's uh a truly great pleasure to uh uh
welcome
felix soto for this uh special
distinguished lecture today so i'm uh
one of the organizers of this uh of this
program uh that's wrapping up this
semester and it's especially i'm
especially happy to be able to make this
introduction because when
in many ways uh felix is gave birth to
the entire idea behind this program
uh so i think auto calculus is really uh
what is driving a lot of us uh for the
methods that we're actually employing
and
some of the
ideas of you know moving particles
thanks to uh vascular and calculus so
i mean i i think it's great to have your
name uh attached to
and uh
but i think uh
it's a it's uh it's really an honor so
we all know this as jko but uh of course
uh even the auto calculus is really what
it's driving us i mean auto jko is
something that makes it more formal
mathematically but uh
uh i i do like to think in in this terms
and it really enlightened me when i
actually came up with it
and uh finally i you know so this is
actually my last day today so i'm very
happy that i can actually attend this
lecture and you all know that i'm making
t-shirts and now i feel really bad
because you really are the name that's
missing right i mean i couldn't come up
with anything smart enough to actually
put your name on a t-shirt but you would
definitely be a great candidate for this
even closer to those so i have to have
my kefir alley t-shirt
and um
and i'm hoping i will actually work hard
to try to come up with a with an auto
one and i'll send
i'll send it to uh to the
participants of the program so without
uh further more further ado i will let
uh felix talk about
mean curvature flow and and gradient
flows thank you thank you for the kind
introduction and uh thanks for the
invitation for the month here it's a
pleasure to be here
uh
so uh so what i um
what we speak about is not related to uh
the
vasa stein or optimum transportation but
it's related to uh to time
discretizations of gradient flows and
in particular kind of ideas which uh
which go back to the georgie
although as i will mention
in the end it might be that uh kind of
the first people really kind of
popularized the minimizing movement
scheme might be again the geometries uh
uh the anger and taylor wong scheme
which i will
mention in in passing
okay so uh so the talk is uh
is a bit of a hybrid uh subject uh
i will start out with uh with a bit of
geometric analysis reminding you what
the uh
flow of a surface by its mean curvature
is
um i i i will tell you that uh and this
because that for for us was the
motivation
um i will tell you that um an us means
uh silly mesidulu
with whom i'm kind of started this
this work actually when both of us were
at the ima at
minneapolis so a connection to material
science
the growth of grains and polycrystals
something i will explain
and then but then the focus will be uh
on making a connection to analysis on
metric spaces
uh so uh so some of the ideas of the
georgie to deal with gradient flows and
but then it will all be applied to a
to very popular and successful numerical
scheme
by um
benz merriman and osher
a so-called thresholding scheme which is
a numerical scheme for in curvature film
so that's the uh that's the plan
so uh so this is just uh just a reminder
of what uh uh
what uh what mean curvature flow is so
the motion of uh
of a surface by uh by its mean curvature
so the mean curvature of a surface is uh
is one of kind of the two uh
most common curvatures of the surface
here it's kind of the the sum of the two
principal curvatures and i will tell you
why this is a natural quantity in a
second
and uh
so
so flow by mean curvature means that uh
whenever uh your surface which bounds
kind of a domain let's say
is is more convex
looking it shrinks and when it's more
concave looking it it grows
and that is in a sense the right sign so
mathematically that's expressed by
saying that the normal velocity is equal
to uh
to the mean curvature again up to the
sign
and and the and the sign is chosen in
such a way
that this is kind of a regularizing uh
motion in the sense that if you start
out with a corrugated surface this will
uh this was without
but uh but in fact that's in a sense
just the small data
behavior uh because of uh the high
non-linearity of the problem in fact
if you're not dealing with curves but
with surfaces
singularities may actually occur
so so we may have this type of neck
pinching and a dumbbell
as indicated here
so it's uh it's uh it's an easy to write
down geometric evolution problem which
does produce uh which does produce
singularities
and in a sentence you may see it as a as
kind of a geometric version of heat flow
or a diffusion equation and it's the uh
extrinsic version of a geometric heat
flow as opposed to ritchie flow which
i'm sure
many of you have heard of which is an
intrinsic version of geometric heat flow
okay so that's a brief reminder of i
mean curvature flow
and and the reason why it's popular in
in modeling and material science
is that it's uh
well i mean it dissipates interfacial
energy and in fact apparently it was
formulated in material science by
mullins before
it was formulated in geometry
and that's uh that's related to uh to
the simple fact that uh mean curvature
so this specific combination of
principal curvatures
has the interpretation of being the
first variation of the of the functional
of the surface area so if a cons if if a
surface has
uh has uh has cons i mean has vanishing
mean curvature
and you uh look at its parallel surfaces
then at least first order they have the
same area
so
what that means for mean curvature flow
is that if you monitor the total surface
area in time
then you always get a non-positive
quantity which you can either write as
uh
the integral of the square of the
curvature or the integral of the square
of the normal velocity
whatever you please so anyway it's clear
that it's a dynamic which dissipates
interfacial energy so that's uh
uh that's what uh what makes it valuable
and uh so one um
one instance where it has been written
down by uh
by uh in material science
is uh when modeling
uh the uh uh
the uh when modeling modeling
polycrystalline materials so uh
so
those are let's say metals which don't
come in form of a clean single crystal
but which are made out of different
grains
which are distinguished by their
different lattice orientation and
clearly since along a grain boundary
uh your atoms are not in a
in their favorite uh position there is
something like at least on the
mesoscopic level an interfacial energy
attached to this to this to this
interface
and what you observe is that
over certain time scales and that
depends on the temperature
such a system tries to reduce the uh
reduce the interfacial area and so for
this mean curvature flow has been
written down
but of course in this type of
application
you never have a single or two grains
but you have many grains and as soon as
you have more than two grains you have
something which uh which is called
triple junctions
so in the real world but this would be
of course some kind of a line uh kind of
a co-damage to object
and uh and then at these triple
junctions let's put think for a moment
of a two-dimensional world
you have an additional condition
which is kind of a force balance between
the surface tensions so
so all the three surface tensions in the
sense pull
if they're all equal they pull in an
equal way and you have an equilibrium
condition here
at the at the triple junction which goes
by the name of
which herring wrote down first
it's an angle condition
and
in in such a situation so when you have
just more than one phase
you have more types of singularities
than the one neck pinching singularity
which i mentioned before
because kind of generically
you would have this type of exchange of
neighboring of
grains
and you would have grains that vanish
like in this situation
and in fact
that's uh that's in the end the
important mechanism for physics for
what's called grain growth
namely that you start out
initially with uh with a configuration
which has a very very fine arrangement
of grains
and then through uh this type of mean
cup multiphase mean curvature flow going
through several
singularities of this type
the uh this configuration coarseness and
the number of grains reduces and this is
something which uh in a certain sense
the statistically similar behavior
of which you would like to understand
and uh
that's another topic which uh i know
from uh from david kindelia who was very
interested in that uh in the last 10 20
years
so uh
so that's where uh kind of multiface i
mean culture flow comes up
and uh uh now let's change
kind of perspective a bit and uh
let me point out i'm
sure some of you are familiar with this
that at least formally
mean curvature flow
no matter whether it's the two-phase or
the multiphase case
can be considered as as gradient flow
so
in in a suitable sense uh this
kind of innocuous looking equation uh
can be interpreted as as a gradient flow
of the surface area with respect to a
formal romanian structure on the on the
surfaces
let's tell you in a second what that
romanian structure is and uh
and
so that's having having this type
of radiant flow structure for an
evolution equation is is something
that's uh valuable because it allows you
to
think in terms of geometry
of infinite dimensional geometry on
configuration space
and as i like to stress
for a gradient flow it's not just the
height function which is the energy
function that matters
but
the
geometry on configuration space so the
notion of distance on the configuration
space is equally important because only
the combination of the two tells you in
which direction your energy landscape is
steep and in which direction it's
shallow so only that combination of
these two tells you
in which direction the system will
develop
will evolve
so uh
so so this uh kind of thinking in terms
of the geometry
uh in in the large is
is helpful
but then you realize uh
and uh that has been done a while ago
that the former romanian geometry which
you need in order to make mean curvature
flow into gradient flow
and that's the
romanian geometry
where the inner product
is the l2 norm or the square l2 norm of
the normal velocity over the surface so
that's a truly romanian structure
because
the inner product depends on the
configuration where you are
that if you write down this type of uh
least least energy problem so you look
at the
energy of a curve which means
integrating
the normal velocity which describes this
curve of configurations
first over the evolving configurations i
know your
time parameter
that this infimum is always equal to
zero so uh so that's a dj as opposed to
the wasserstein
geometry this is at first
you lose all hope because uh because you
can't really give a sense to that uh to
that distance functionally large
and um so
but let's not worry about this for for a
moment
and uh let's do as if uh uh
we uh we had a nice distance function
for this problem or a proxy to
the distance function
then something uh
which
which in a certain sense i grew up with
is to write down
the time discretization of such a
gradient flow
and the kind of conceptual advantage of
writing ta writing down a time
discretization is in a sense it looks
much more robust you don't need
derivatives
you just need your distance function
and your energy functional you don't
need any gradient of your energy or
that kind of stuff so there's something
which you can formulate in the constant
context of the metric space
and uh so uh
so you minimize uh you minimize the
squared distance to your previous
configuration with one over two times
this time step size plus the energy
function
so that's uh that's minimizing movements
and uh
and in the in the euclidean case
when your metric space is euclidean
space
then it's easy to see uh if you write
down the first variation of this
variation problem
that what you're doing is really just
the implicit or backwards euler scheme
discretization of that gradient flow
that's what it that's what it boils down
to
so um
so far so good
and uh then you get very excited
because uh this variational
this variation problem in a sense gives
you an estimate
for free
because uh you can always
compare
your minimal energy
uh
to uh
to comparing it to the previous uh to
the previous
configuration
and if you do that
and you write down these kind of for
every time step you write down the
inequality which you get from the simple
comparison and you sum them up you get
this type of
by telescoping you get this type of uh
this type of a clean inequality
which tells you uh not only that the
energy kind of always decreases always
below the initial energy but it also
gives you uh gives you control over this
uh kind of
length term this dissipative term
and now now you look uh now at first
you're extremely excited or you know
when at least an analyst would be very
excited
because uh in your mind you would try
already to pass to the limit letting the
time step size go to zero
and if you do that
you get uh you get something which looks
like the energy identity for gradient
flow
and uh but
there is one problem
there's a factor of one half here which
is too much
so uh so the simple mind that
a priori estimate which you get from the
variational structure
of this time step minimization
in a sense misses a factor of one half
and therefore it's certainly not
in any way sufficient to characterize
the dynamics
that's
kind of
a fact of life and that was exactly what
uh kind of the georgie
realized uh probably he was not first to
realize it but he was
somebody who wrote down kind of who
gave ideas how to overcome this
and uh so the two uh the two tools he uh
he came up with uh are the uh what's
called the variational interpolation on
the one hand
and the metric slope uh on the other
hand so that's explained on this slide
so uh
so the more subtle quest the more subtle
tool is this variational interpolation
and it
it's related to the fact that
if you want to kind of do uh let the
time step size go to zero connect to a
kind of a limiting uh
evolution
uh well i mean the naive thing you would
do is you would somehow interpolate your
discrete solution
in time
over your time steps of size h
and the simplest way of course is to
take just the piecewise constant
in time interpolation
but you can do a smarter way i mean now
as a numerical analyst at first you
would say well let's do it piecewise
linear
but that doesn't make any sense because
m doesn't have even a linear structure
so so doing a piecewise linear
interpolation doesn't have any meaning
at this stage
and so what the georgie proposed is to
just use the tools
which you have at your disposal namely
the metric and the energy functional to
construct an interpolation that in a
certain sense mimics a continuous
interpolation
and he does that by just playing with
the uh
with the time step size parameter
if f
goes to zero then this term is penalized
a lot so the minimizer will be very
close to chi n minus 1 for the previous
time step
and if s is equal to h well you get the
variational problem which defines the
next time step
so in principle
this should provide
that's not necessarily a continuous but
a reasonable intrinsic interpolation of
these two configurations
so that's the first idea
and the second idea is to
say well i mean although we don't really
have access to a gradient
uh in a purely metric geometry we have
access to something which you may think
of as a as as as as the length of a
gradient as the slope
by using it by looking at the usual
difference quotient
and now uh now he introduced these two
notions of the variational interpolation
yes
uh if the distance is at the equilibrium
distance this corresponds to
what
is linear
that's a good question i would assume
yes
i would assume that uh
that if the
uh well now it also depends on this
functional here right so
it's it's something else right uh
if uh if this here would be just the
norm squared then probably it would be
the piecewise linear but even in the
even in the even in the euclidean case
this would be something non-linear
good question
okay so
so he introduced these tools because
then he could do
he could write down something so with
these tools
you can write down an inequality
which
looks a little bit like what you would
naively do so there is the
energy at time step n there's the
initial energy there's one half times
this metric term
but what he gains
is
this second term here
which involves the metric slope and
which involves the variational
interpolation
and that's completely general
uh general inequality
and so why did he like it and why why
why do we like it
because in a sense again it suggests
that you may pass to the limit in this
inequality
so passing to the limit in this metric
term
should give you kind of the
the energy of the curve up to a factor
one
half and passing
passing to the limit in this
in this slope term
and this gradient term at least if you
were in the romanian context
should give you uh
the squared norm squared euclidean norm
of gradient
so
so you you you believe that there is a
one-to-one correspondence
between this discrete inequality which
is exact
and this limiting
continuum inequality
and then you realize that this limiting
of euclidean this limiting continuum
inequality
despite the fact that it's just an
inequality in fact is equivalent
to the gradient flow formulation
that you just see by
writing this difference of energies as
the time integral over the time
derivative of the energy and using chain
rule
and then you see that what you get is
exactly what you need to complete the
square and then the inequality is enough
to give you this result
so that's uh that's another key idea of
the georgie that
it's enough to have an inequality
to
to characterize a gradient flow
and that of course now kind of cries out
for soft methods
so you would expect that
you can use this strategy
to prove not just convergence of
gradient flows but you know even in more
complicated situations where
homogenization is involved to pass to
the limit in this type of inequality
information
because all you need is lower
semi-continuity so it looks as kind of
extremely extremely promising and
powerful tool
but
but that's uh
so far i don't think it has been used uh
used a lot and and what i want to
present is kind of one one
application of this
okay so last last of the four topics is
this numerical scheme for
for mean curvature flow
which
is
is extremely intuitive and extremely
easy to write down
and so it was introduced uh almost 30
years ago
and uh uh it's uh it's the following
idea so you describe
you describe a set
and you're interested in the boundary
and the evolution of the boundary of the
set by its characteristic function so
it's
equal to one inside and equal to zero
outside
so it's uh in every time step you do two
two operations two simple operations
um you solve the heat equation
uh for this time step h which means uh
essentially you're convolving with the
heat kernel or
you're convolving with gaussian of
variance h
so then you get
you get kind of this red function which
has values typically strictly between 0
and 1.
that's the convolution step
and then in the uh
thresholding step you ask where this new
function is larger or smaller than one
half
and that gives you new characteristic
function
and that gives you kind of a new set
after you know
the
one step further in the
in the time so let me uh
show you one uh one numerical simulation
here
uh so we start out with this kind of
peanut shape
we do the convolution step then of
course you get blurry
and then we look for the level set one
half
and that defines the new set and you
already see that
in a certain sense it has done a little
bit the right thing
because
these two points have moved in because
if you take the convolution
around the point here on the boundary
you see more white than black because
the convolution kernel is really
symmetric
so at this point after convolution your
function will be less than one half
so this point will
then lie here in the white region
whereas if you do it in this point here
provided h is sufficiently small
you see more black than white
so that one will have moved out
so it's a it's it clearly qualitatively
does the right thing
and
and also numerically it's extremely
performant because
now you can discretize it in space you
could do that in either simple way
and then you use fast fourier transform
to carry out the convolution
or you do it in a smarter way
where you just monitor kind of small
neighborhoods of
of the interface and use
things which have been developed here
by jamie sethian like the forest
marching algorithm so that's a very
very performant numerical scheme for
mean curvature flow
and uh um
and like all good schemes
it kind of preserves the property of the
uh
of the continuum
of the of the of the limiting problem
and that's comparison
so uh this scheme clearly has the
property
if initially or at the previous time
step your two sets are nested which
means you have inequality between the
two characteristic functions
that's preserved by convolution with a
non-negative kernel like gaussian
and that's preserved by thresholding
and uh and that's exactly also the
property which we know from from mean
curvature flow from one or two phase
mean curvature flow that this nestedness
is being preserved
and that uh
thanks to this very perform
very practical and powerful method of
viscosity solutions
already allows you to give kind of a
convergence proof of the scheme
which uh you know craig evans started
that and a number of people were
involved
uh
to uh to uh to this uh kind of soft
notion of
of mean curvature flow
so it's a good scheme because it
preserves one of uh one of the kind of
crucial properties of the of the
continuum
evolution which is comparison principle
now it it's also a good scheme because
uh it can be without any problems it can
be extended to the multi-face case i
mean uh here
it's very easy now you have kind of
ingest of having instead of just having
a single characteristic function
you have n characteristic functions
which kind of fill up space
uh so in the in the two-phase case what
i see you would have two uh two
characteristics functions chi and one
minus chi now you have n
and larger than two
and you do exactly the same thing you uh
you convolve each of them with uh with
your gaussian
and then you ask the question which of
the which of the ones is largest
and here it's kind of there's an
indication in terms of color
uh so we start out with this
configuration
and here the angle condition is clearly
not satisfied we blur the picture
then we threshold and already after one
time step you get the uh the right
condition at the triple point
uh and so on
and uh and this has been uh proven to uh
uh to work uh in engineering
applications with uh hundred thousands
of grains in three dimensions so it's a
very performing uh performance numerical
scheme
and uh but the uh but the theory in the
multi-phase case is more subtle because
you don't have a comparison principle so
you have to resort to other notions of
solution from in curvature flow
and it was only fairly recently that
keymantonigawa showed that
there is convergence to uh to this
notion by bacca which i have perhaps i
have the time to mention it later
and but there is also quite some
activity on the in the two-dimensional
case the coarsening of networks
and uh trying to construct more
classical solutions in this case
so that's the uh uh that's the
multi-phase case
and and so the the the two questions we
contributed a bit to
are the following
um so in in grain growth
uh
you don't want the surface tension
to be uh always equal in fact you want
to be able to choose surface tensions
which can be
different for every
pair of grains so depending on whether
you you connect one and three or two and
one you want to be able to impose a
different type of surface tension
so how can you modify
this
very simple multiphase thresholding
scheme which i wrote down before
in order to accommodate for more general
surface tensions
that was not clear
and uh
and uh
and kind of i will show you very very
simple idea of how to do that
and the second question is uh can one
give a convergence result also in the
multiphase case
so the first uh is his work with uh
last is uh work with uh former phd
student tim laughs who was postdoc here
in uh
in berkeley and now is back in bonn or
as in bon
and
and both ideas rely on the fact that
surprisingly uh but in a very simple way
this thresholding scheme can be
interpreted as a minimizing movement
scheme
at first it doesn't look
variational at all right it's just uh in
a certain sense convolving and then
thresholding i mean it's clear that in a
certain sense it has the max or the
comparison principle built in
but uh you don't see
that it has the uh
that it has any type of gradient flow
built in but in fact uh it does
and uh and in a certain sense the
observation is almost you know i mean
it's just one one line it's a very
simple observation
it's uh it's just on the slide so here
again
i wrote down in one line what this two
tier
what this two stage thresholding scheme
means
you take the previous time step size i
just do it in the two-phase case now
you take the previous time step skill
size you convolve it with the gaussian
you ask where it's larger than one-half
that gives you the new characteristic
function
so in fact this characteristic function
minimizes
a functional which has the structure
of a term
which uh is
that this is square distance to the
previous time step
because this first term here
is uh uh is kind of the uh
in some sense modified
l2
type of uh in a inner product squared
and since the fourier transform of
the gaussian which is again a gaussian
is non-negative this here is indeed
a strictly positive this is indeed a
norm squared
and a second part uh
which i will show you in a second can be
interpreted as an energy
and so this very simple observation is
that uh this function here
minimizes this uh this function here
among all functions which have values
even between one i mean they don't have
to be characteristic functions between
zero and one
and it's just linear algebra
you just rewrite this term
in this in this way here
and uh
in which case by the symmetry of this
convolution kernel
you get v times this red expression plus
something which doesn't depend on uh
on v anymore
and then clearly in order to minimize
this you want v to be equal to one where
this is positive and you want it equal
to zero
where this is negative and that's
exactly this choice here
so it's uh it's really just an
embarrassingly simple observation
that uh that this scheme has this
variational interpretation
now of course that could be completely
unrelated to mean curvature flow but in
fact it's not
and that's uh
that's the uh the main i the main inside
so
so here again is the uh is the
variational structure so here you have
this square distance term
and here you have uh uh this term which
i want to see as an energy
and now perhaps i first should convince
you that this is indeed something like a
surface energy
so let's look at this term uh a bit more
carefully for a characteristic function
chi
uh so what are you doing here
you're taking your characteristic
function chi
and you're convolving it it means you
smear it out
and then you take the product with with
the complement uh you integrate this
characteristic function of the
complement you take the product with one
minus chi
so what you measure is this integral
here
and you measure that along the entire
interface and since the profile
kind of modulates the interface
it's not surprising that this here to
leading order
is proportional to the length of the
area of the interface provided you
rescale it in the right way with one of
the square root of h because that's
the length of the kernel this is how
much spills out here
and that's exactly what here what's what
you have here so in a in a way which i
will make precise
more precise in a second
this here indeed as h goes to zero looks
like the interfacial energy looks like
the
length of the interface
and in a very similar way you can also
convince yourself that the first
that the first term the symmetric term
uh in a certain sense picks out
the uh the amount by which you displace
the new interface with respect to the
old interface
so so both terms from this
heuristic point of view have clearly a
connection
to mean curvature flow
so
and now the uh the observation is that
also kind of in the multi-phase case
when all the surface tensions are are
equal
uh
this variational interpretation persists
in this case the energy
turns out to be be this expression so
for any pairs of phases
i and j which are different
you look at the similar type of
expression you kind of
take the integral take the convolution
of the j phase you look how much of it
gets into the i face
and in fact uh there are interesting
gamma convergence results which show
that this function here gamma converges
exactly i mean every part converges to
the interface between i and j
which you can express in uh
by using bit of bv calculus in this way
and uh um and then if you take this as
the energy that has to be the distance
function
which is uh which is indeed a distance
function so
also in this multiphase case
thresholding
can be interpreted in this variational
case in this variational way
so
what's the advantage now
so one one advantage is more applied
math
that
this now gave us the idea of how to
modify the thresholding scheme in order
to
allow for
different
interfacial energies depending on which
pair of phases you have
but just taking the old expression and
putting a sigma ij here where sigma ij
is the interfacial energy
between grain i or face i and face j
and uh
and then
write down a variational problem
variational formulation exactly uh
exactly in the same way
and then see what it means in terms of
whether it can be interpreted in terms
of thresholding and yes it can
and it has you know it has exactly the
same complexity as the equal phase case
of thresholding the only difference is
that in the convolution step
you take this
you take a combination which is weighted
by the surface tension
so that's the way how you should kind of
make the sigma ijs enter in your
thresholding scheme
in order to get uh
to get multiphase mean curvature flow
so without any
dirty tricks and without any increase in
complexity
you can occur you can accommodate uh
different uh
uh n over two different surface tensions
into the scheme so that was uh
kind of the applied math uh
um uh consequence of this inside
and uh
okay that's one that's one slide because
uh
for this to work
we need two conditions on the sigma ijs
so we need the triangle inequality
which is something very physical
and uh which you would uh
have no problems to uh
allow for
but we also need kind of a negative
semi-definiteness
on uh
on this on the matrix where you put the
sigma ijs off diagonal
and uh on the hype on this hyperplane
and that's uh that's a condition which
is not automatically fulfilled
and it has to do with embeddability
of these uh of these uh sigma ijs of
these numbers sigma j's as distances
in a potentially high dimensional space
in four uh
up to four different phases it's almost
it's always satisfied but if you have
more than four phases it's not clear
so at first it was not clear whether
what we're doing
is practical
but then we checked that it's uh
this condition is satisfied for the most
common
model in in grain growth
which which goes by the name of reed
shockley
where you say that the interfacial
energy
between a pair of grains is related to
the misorientation i mean how much do
you have to rotate
how much do you have to rotate the uh
the lattice
in order to go from this grain to this
grain
so uh
so what matters is kind of the relative
orientation in terms of angles up to the
symmetry let's say the octahedral group
and then kind of and there is some
microscopic modeling which goes into
this
uh the most common
way you would have the surface energy
depend on the angle is in this
logarithmic way
and that uh
that does satisfy the condition so so
therefore what we're doing is is
practical
because also this negative semi-definite
condition is
is satisfied here
okay so how much time do i have
15.
yes then uh so let me tell you a bit
about the um
so that was the work with silly music
then with tim laughs we uh
we said now that we have this uh
that we have this kind of variational
interpretation this minimizing movements
interpretation
let's see whether we can we can get a
convergence proof from there
and uh
we did that in the multi-phase case but
i'm going to tell it to you just in the
two-phase case because then there's less
to write
and the question now is is is of course
uh
very natural you suppose that you have
initial data which have finite parameter
in this pv notation
and uh
and then you you you run thresholding
and the usual thresholding which does
have this variational interpretation but
you don't care if you run your usual
thresholding and you ask the question
does it converge
and we have three different convergence
results which are all conditional in a
way which i'm going to explain to you
to
three different types of solutions and
perhaps the most interesting one is the
last one which is actually
which we proved last and where the proof
is
uh softest
uh and that's connecting to uh to do
georgie's uh
notion which i which i mentioned at the
beginning and uh
but in all of these notions we we use
kind of a little bit of
geometric measure theory to be able to
express what uh
mean curvature flow is i'm sure many of
you have seen
this concept anyway i already used the
notation of
expressing
interfacial area defined by a
characteristic function via the bv norm
that relates to catiopolis sets
that also gives rise to measure
theoretic normal via polar factorization
in the same way you can introduce
a normal a normal velocity just again by
putting all derivatives onto the test
function
and in fact you can also introduce me in
curvature i mean curvature in this way
by integration by part so you have
access to all these geometric notions
in this uh in this robust and
soft context which
of course is well very well known from
from
minimal surfaces
and so
so the first result we got a while ago
is that indeed
the scheme converges
to such a weak notion of mean curvature
flow which can have singularities
in the sense that there exists a normal
velocity which is an l2 in space-time
over the interface
so defined by this equation such that
the mean curvature is equal to this
velocity
and mean curvature is defined by this
type of integration by parts
so that would be great but
the convergence result we get is a
conditional convergence result we have
to make an assumption
and
and now in perhaps the last
couple of minutes i want to explain to
you
why this assumption is
why first of all we're in good company
with this assumption and you know this
assumption probably is is not so easy to
get rid of
and how it connects to a
uh to a famous uh minimizing movement
scheme for me in curvature flow which
was first formulated i'm green tail and
one
so here again is our result so we get
convergence of the thresholding scheme
to
mean curvature flow in this bv notion
provided
we have convergence of the energies
what we get for free for by lower
semi-continuity of the parameter is one
inequality but here we're imposing
convergence of the energies so bv
convergence and that's more what we
would get out of the typical
energy estimate
so we were not too worried about this
and got our paper accepted because
because exactly the same assumption was
made by
my advisor and somebody who did a phd
his phd the same time as i did
on a scheme which is
which perhaps might be even more
influential than the thresholding scheme
but which is completely academic
which is the
atw scheme the anger and taylor wong
scheme and you haven't heard of it you
should
you should know it because i think that
was the minimizing movement scheme
before the ladder even the people in
pisa admit to the fact that this was
their first
so uh
so i'm grant
taylor and juan
wrote down a minimizing movement scheme
for mean curvature flow which takes this
form here which exactly has
kind of minimizing movement form
you minimize the surface area
of your current configuration i mean you
minimize the surface area you find the
next
the next configuration by minimizing the
surface area plus
1 over 2h times the square distance
function
and
now the distance function they put is is
kind of
judiciously designed but it's very
geometric so
what do they consider they take
the previous time step
and then they look at the distance
function the unsigned distance function
to the previous time step
and integrate that over the
kind of excess area
of the current time step with respect to
the previous time step
so that doesn't have a much of a
numerical appeal to it
but it was very influential in terms of
uh
in terms of theoretical tool
in terms of thinking about mean culture
flow
and uh and now this work by uh
by lukause and stutznecker was the first
one
that showed that indeed the scheme
does converge in this conditional sense
i mean i'm going to tell a wong had a
also convergence result in their paper
but that was on a much stronger
assumption
so
uh so so so so the the the interesting
thing i mean is
what i find nice is that in some sense
we now discovered that the most popular
numerical scheme exactly has the same
structure
and that in fact this structure of the
numerical scheme
can be used to give the same type of
conditional convergence result which
people gave for
this academic scheme
okay so i'm going to finish soon
now in a certain sense what we were not
so happy with
about this result here is
that it did not at all connect
to the gradient flow structure
in fact these weak this weak formulation
by itself is not sufficient to show that
the energy decreases in time
and uh so therefore we said
let's connect
to a notion of mean curvature flow
which has this property built in
and there is such a notion of mean
curvature flow which is due to baca
which is here
which
not just expresses mean curvature flow
as an inequality
but it also i mean it it's really um if
if if the evolution was smooth it's
equivalent to mean curvature flow
and it has the advantage that it doesn't
refer to the normal velocity
it just refers to the curvature itself
and expresses the dynamics like this and
it contains the energy dissipation
inequality
so uh so that's probably also very kind
of
important uh inside that
you can encode
a complicated pde or geometric evolution
in terms of an inequality very much like
the georgie
kind of said we can encode gradient flow
by an inequality and then what we did is
uh we used kind of the georgie's ideas
for gradient for for metric radian flows
to derive this bracket notion
so that was the uh that was the second
result
but then we said okay perhaps we can
even make it simpler and that was the
last result which just appeared in the
proceeding
by really taking the georgie
uh literally and passing to the limit in
in this type of inequality and that also
works
and that proof is indeed surprisingly
soft so uh so in that proof we still
need our condition i mean our
it's still the same conditional result
but with this additional assumption
uh showing the lower semi-continuity of
these terms
in in the mean curvature sense which
would be this here
is uh is surprisingly soft so uh so in a
certain sense our results went from
being pretty hard and using
rectifiability and that kind of stuff
to in the end being extremely soft
and just using the ideas of the georgie
so i have a couple of slides of these
ideas but probably i should stop and uh
and
and come with a summary so uh
so uh
so in a certain sense that was a little
bit of uh an overview which kind of
brought
different subjects together
geometric evolution
applications in material science
pretty abstract analysis on metric
spaces
and uh
and this uh
this very practical a numerical tool of
uh of thresholding
which uh which here come together
and uh uh and are connected
okay so let me stop
there any questions you know
also you mentioned that in the romanian
structure of the curvature flow it's
genuinely in the sense that the metric
depends on your current configuration is
that so true for the the scheme
no so the discrete scheme uh the metric
is really uh even euclidean
but um
but it's not the limiting metric right
so
it's a little bit
in a certain sense the uh passing to the
limit in the metric is subtle
uh in in when you restrict it onto
characteristic functions
it plays this kind of geometric role but
before you do that in the scheme itself
it's completely euclidean
let me give you an analogy i don't know
how much you're
familiar with uh
either
kind of i mean with free boundary
problems in solidification like male and
sikurka stefan problem
does that ring a belt
so there there are three boundary
motions uh where which can be seen as
gradient flow with respect to the h
minus one metric
which is euclidean right h minus one
that's a hilbert tilde space
and but still uh in the limit and you
can write down the time discretization
which just sees the h minus one metric
but the limit uh is kind of the limit
you have a truly romanian uh romanian
structure because your
risk because your space
on which you restrict this metric is a
curved space namely the space of kind of
characteristic functions which doesn't
have a linear structure anymore so i
would say here
it's a bit the same phenomenon
that in this numerical scheme
this metric i can show it again
is completely um
yeah this
this metric is is is you know i mean
it's euclidean it's this it's the
ukrainian metric
uh but uh in in in in the limit it turns
into something relative because you're
restricted in the end you're restricting
to characteristic functions
i hope that
answers the question
this is like a similar form with like uh
it's like
sometimes this distance because if you
take the fourier transform you get like
e to the minus e to the t squared times
the square of the
of the of the function in there yes so
it's a very negative it's very negative
for you norm right because you're
thanks to the convolution you get rid of
all the small wavelength
so it's uh it's uh
uh
but but then it depends on h right the
norm itself depends on h in a subtle way
and not just because of the prefactor
but also because it's in the current
there we had another question sorry i'm
going to start in order to join please
uh yeah in the uh
so in the
when the sigma ijs fail to satisfy the
triangle inequality of negative
definiteness
at least at the very end the
thresholding speed that we proposed on
the base of this i mean that at least
seems reasonable even if the sigma ijs
don't satisfy these conditions so i mean
what
a lot of these so so um so i mean the
the scheme
um
where is it
so so this scheme looks pretty oblivious
to whether these things are negative
definite or not
but uh
we couldn't show i mean if those are not
negative definite
we couldn't show we wouldn't have this
uh assured property that this energy
function decreases from step to step
because the difference would be given by
quantity of which we can no longer
control of the site
so so therefore even kind of the very
first step of our convergence proof
uh would break down
now i don't remember whether
celine did numerical simulations in such
a situation whether in fact also
the scheme would start being
unreasonable that i don't remember
that's a good question but uh
you might have well done that
so as you know
in the two-phase case
if you use a level set method you can
develop a carrier
i assume that can happen
in these various interpretations here
no that so so uh
um so that's not so much so the problem
here is
that you cannot rule out a ghost
interface right that uh
uh two uh
kind of uh two interfaces
in this limiting process would approach
and then in the limit you don't know
whether you should keep it in with
multiplicity 2
or not
but
but fattening in a sense is ruled out
because
um
because you have this i mean i don't
know if that's perhaps that's too naive
an answer but uh but we i mean we uh we
do control the uh
uh this pv norm at every step i mean
fattening is what the price you pay to
get uniqueness of the plus yes yes and
so then there's no uniqueness there's no
there's no uniqueness but still i mean
still you would get convergence to
something that's non-fattening force for
subsequence that's right so if you start
out with if you start out with initial
data
uh uh which would give you fattening in
the uh in in the
of course the uh
uh um
this scheme
uh uh would select
what i mean by passing to subsequence
you would get one of the two solutions
one question
yes um i i think maybe i i
went by a little fast i just wanted to
clarify when you said that the
assumption you require for your
conditional convergence result um is the
same as it appeared in this previous
work by luke house do you mean indeed
this exact same energy appeared in their
previous work is that this need to be
valid or just the analogous
an analogous assumption because they
don't uh
so they don't have this object but they
what they uh
what they suppose is that uh
that the parameter of this thing does
not
yeah i don't know
do you have any questions
so i i do have a question which reflects
my lack of knowledge of geometry quote
uh um
so i was under is this let's say i
started geometrical and run it for
infinite time on some body for example
is that going to collapse to a point or
is it going or can i scale it so that it
actually remains the body maybe like
some sort of ball
okay so so
here if you have two phases um
and you have kind of uh
you're not in a very unstable situ an
initial condition
it will always collapse to a point
but it's not difficult to modify the
scheme in such a way that you preserve
the
volume
so that's volume preserved mean
curvature flow in which case it would
converge to ball
and so so that's modification of the
scheme
you can do that both on the level of the
numerical scheme
and on the level of this variational
analysis and tim
is going to just have some topological
singularities along the way right
so so that does not rule out topological
singularities and uh and so for dumbbell
initial data
if uh
uh
so let's say let's say
it would be slightly asymmetric probably
you would first uh now that's without
yeah so with the volume constraint
probably what would happen first is that
uh it would pinch off
and you would have two two balls
uh if they don't have exactly the same
radius there would be some kind of
ostrich ripening in the sense that the
smaller one would shrink and the larger
one would converge to uh
to the limit
and so the the question i had was is
this a variational perspective of them
in curvature flow
suggest some guidelines as to you know
some developing some other geometric
flows for example that would avoid
singularities in this setup or
probably not and in fact i would say um
the
these singularities are perhaps
something which you do want
right i mean both both in imaging
applications i think
if you if you try to kind of find a
contour so
i think uh
you would like your uh your scheme to
actually be able to pinch off
and to kind of enclose
and close something which has uh which
has you know low contrast
and that you would do but i'm sure
you're more familiar with this than i am
by um
by introducing some kind of
heterogeneity in the uh
in the interfacial energy that uh
the interfacial energy is low
where uh you have high contrast in the
image
so that curves would like to migrate
there and stay there but then exactly in
such an application i think you very
much
like this
be able to
the possibility of the scheme to change
change topology and thereby
necessarily have a singularity
depending on the data such that you
preserve the volumes of the sensor
so in order to let these uh
converge to
the minimal cluster configuration or
something
no
but uh but again uh also in the
multi-face case uh so if you don't uh
uh if you uh i mean generically you will
get the sportsman right
and that's what people you know
capturing this is exactly what people
are would be interested in in material
science
now if you want to uh
if you if you if you want to converge to
an hexagonal lattice you could do the
same thing you can prescribe the volume
of each of the phases
by by slight kind of modification of the
scheme
and then presumably
you would expect that you would converge
to hexagonal ladders
let's say the volumes of the phases as
people
so i was
yeah yeah i mean that that in principle
i think that can be so so i mean
imposing uh imposing i mean
the scheme both
the practical scheme and the variational
interpretation can be twisted in such a
way that uh no matter whether
in and out or more than just two phases
in order to preserve the volume
so in principle that that could be i
mean one could run in numerical
experiments too for this type of cluster
problem
more questions
soon
is there any chance to make a
convergence result
quantitative namely the order of error
in time step h
um
so
so i think um
if
not now i think uh this is what aaron
yip and drew schwartz did
that they um
in a smooth situation
kind of wrote down a real asymptotic
development of this
of this mbo scheme
so
so i think like always when you want to
do when you want to have a quantitative
convergence result here which
would be a first order for this type of
scheme
and second order in space first are in
time
you can do that as long as you are
close to smooth limiting configurations
in moments of topology transition you
would expect that this convergence
breaks down
and just by the fact as
craig just said that you have
non-uniqueness and kind of of course
non-uniqueness is a
is an obstacle to any type of
convergence proof
but but as long as the limiting
configuration is smooth
but it's conceivable and i think in some
sense it has been done
thank you
all right so let's think thanks again
we have refreshments
[Music]